it was my first time headlining at the
comedy stars in the bedroom I was all
excited like I wonder where they'd asked
me to do this like six years ago turns
out there's like six people in the crowd
and it was the the opening game of the
World Series with the Dodgers so there's
nobody there so I feel like a piece of
[ __ ] but then Dave Chappelle walks in
he's in the Green Room he's like hey
you're running the show I'm like yeah
the headliner he's like you mind if I do
a set man is that cool with you I'm like
sure you do whatever whatever you want
right so we're in the green room talking
and there's like I'm feeling so sad
there's only seven people in there and
me and him are vibing like this is so
[ __ ] dope man Dave Chappelle and then
he's vaping and I go oh it just ruined
our relationship he probably hates me to
this day if he even remembers me he's
vaping I go oh you know those are worse
for you than cigarettes he goes what the
[ __ ] you just said
it you know the Vapes actually worse for
you than cigarettes he goes who told you
that like oh it's just what to say he's
like who says that I'm like oh [ __ ] dude
wow he's like my doctor says better
that's why he told me started vaping
like but I don't think it is
and he's like all right man and just
walked off never talk to him again I
ruined my relationship with Dave
Chappelle over Vape